we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 David P
uh the anti-vaxxers have immediately
swarmed over what happened on the field
on Monday where a football player Damar
Hamlin
um suffered a cardiac arrest and uh here
is uh here's a call about exactly that
hey David
this is her from the Philadelphia
suburbs yes calling about uh something
that I've seen
um circulating around the internet uh
over the past few days since the Lamar
Hamlin medical scare earlier this week
the safety from the Buffalo Bills who
had a cardiac arrest
um in certain areas of conspiracist
right meaning
uh social media there is a true
attribution that it's because of a
coveted vaccine
rather than the fact that a six foot
four 220 pound opponent struck him in
the chest running full force right
um I'm a medical doctor uh I can tell
you that
um one of those causes is far more
likely and that I think it has more to
do with the one
um that's gonna knock you on your back
rather than eating a Band-Aid on your
deltoid however I don't think you need
10 years of postgraduate training to
know that I think so yeah and and again
we do not even know the vaccination
status of Demar Hamlin or at least we
didn't as of yesterday when I I last
read about this and there are so many
leaps in logic that are being made here
that it is really it's truly a scary
thing that these folks for whom again
they've got a hammer which is vaccines
are bad that's their Hammer so
everything is a nail someone gets
covered oh it's because of the vaccine
someone has a heart attack it's because
of the vaccine someone dies it's because
of the vaccine everything is the vaccine
because all they've got is a hammer and
it's a really sad situation we've got
and a destructive one I should add great
bonus show for you today we'll talk
about
um something interesting going on with
Millennials in politics
Southwest Airlines involved in a
controversy a Maga hat wearing teacher
has been
um in a sense Vindicated legally all of
it is on the bonus show today oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yeah everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad sign up at
joinpakman.com and we will see you then